Kourtney Kardashian and Scott Disick hug
it out I want to be able to be the man
that you've always wanted important you
were snapped shopping together at a
William Sonoma in Calabasas it's this
pic of the pair with their arms wrapped
around each other that has fans
wondering if they're back on but a
source close to Kourtney tells et if
they aren't the pair was just picking up
items for Scott's new home quote arms
around each other and embracing are not
abnormal for them if she was actually
considering getting back together with
him she would definitely handle it more
privately they are not back together the
exes who split in July share three kids
together and have remained close and
Scott's been vocal about wanting to make
lifestyle changes he appeared on Khloe
Kardashian's talk show last week the
only thing I'm trying to focus on is
just calming down and focusing on the
kids and just trying to be a good dad
last month
Khloe addressed whether she thinks
they'll ever get back together
I mean potential for anything I think
their focus right now is the kids and
Scott just being healthy and focusing on
himself